ciao a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa dj ed anti
caccia è finito il titolo ed oggi siamo
su un guaio one se se il titolo rimane
per cinque secondi
acquario was not use comunque ragazzi
quello è uno ha praticamente dei giochi
più famosi che ci sono per la volevo
assolutamente farlo perché veramente io
da piccolo giocavo in casinò wario lo
preferivo anche a mario sinceramente
perché mi piaceva di più non lo so
perché forse perché non ha senso
comunque ragazzi praticamente merola non
me lo so spiegare iniziamo con ragazzi
sto gioco consiste in poche parole nel
completare dei minigiochi cioè prima
almeno quello che avevo su gameboy
advance era così malaccio l'avevo tipo
dieci anni fa una cosa i ragazzi
consiste nel completare videogiochi in i
giochi anzi che a quanto ne so
dovrebbero licenziare tipo adesso credo
di sì che cos'è il litigi il telecomando
che quel questo questo ce l'ho ce l'ho
mi la bacchetta multiforme tricca
puntandoli navette
questa semplice posture imita uno degli
sport più belli aggressivi che si
conoscano lo zar
ma sono allo zapping ragazza mi che sono
già partiti fai da te cazzo già grande
ragazzi siamo già partiti io non so
niente c'è un ragazzo si muove la metti
a fuoco
si ok un attimo perché dovevo farmi
fatevi prendere la mano un tutorial non
c'è infilza ciclica posizione negozio a
demoni si è fermi nati brady lati c'è
grande ragazzi se avete bisogno di una
spuntatina io ci sono io ci sono
perché ci riesco riuscirà scaccia
schiaccia qualcuno c'è grande amica
senza senza allenamento la prima volta
che sto provando più mela sono a caso
zero vedi distaccando un attimo alla 66
gira virtuosa giro argentina e ve
l'avevo detto che non avevano un senso
alcuno più villa sì grazie
sono non ha ancora perso una cazzo di
vita e siamo a livello 8 lo sapevo che
non dovevo dirlo lo sapevo non ridete su
questo cos'è dettagli rega che calzava
falco non era gol era una lettera al
boss e ragazze era il boss cazzo
ho vinto guardavo dei ragazzi adesso si
va più veloce o guadagnate una vita
prima mente ogni volta che si batte il
vostro si va più veloci ed è un casino
agganciano ok c'è grande senza fai così
vai così sono carico sono carico gas
io sono non lo facciamo così per devo
sempre
[Musica]
ma che cazzo ma [ __ ] ragazzi non è
possibile che a fuoco metti a fuoco ci
si ammala caccia possiamo fare al 15
comincio mi gioco il 35 sono convinto
più veloce ancora mai non me ne te non
me ne frega un cazzo mi muovo club si
muove sta roba che io sto visto sto
sudando una vita sola mica quanto ho
detto 35 cazzo 35 non ho perso quattro
posti quattro volte penso di aver perso
non mi sono sbagliato io sì delle 18 non
so che il braccio ancora ma i giochi mai
giusto non so bastava fun cool devi
morire e devi morire ma porca [ __ ]
sempre se si erano fuori 6 bastardo due
anni per farlo due sono un po più il
braccio cazzo dammi una vita stronzo più
o meno no cazzo più veloce che già non
ce la faccio così a 24 mila ragazzi io
da piccolo non miss calcolavo e per
questo è solo unicamente per questo e
cioè il nostro gioco perché puoi fare
puttanate a caso the distanti come non
so cosa bella e ragazzi madonna sembra
sailor moon era asi innamorato ma che
bello mona sembra un insulto ma in poche
parole ci dovrebbero essere video
concentrare sul gioco vai zio fa il
colpo su di lei e io sono lui a sono
quel tizio mai uno trova lo dò la cosa
il caso è quello primo andato a cosa
possiamo fare colombre l'ombrello tieni
la bacchetta multiforme in posizione
verticale con il pollice appena
appoggiato sul pulsante con questa
postura assomiglia atteggiamento
composto e dignitoso di un pagliaccio
nel bel mezzo di un temporale arrivati
caso abbiate pazienza ma qualcuno ma lo
sapeva abbiamo vinto vinto tutto ciò
fare dove si è stato un mirato scaccia
mi chiamavano fa vide killer ai ragazzi
ovviamente avete visto la procura prima
di iniziare tutti i giochi altra cosa
non la sapevo
ok perché gli è uscita una banana dal
naso car che cazzo di sesso a manubrio
[Musica]
che cazzo fatto bello mai come mai
colonnello arriva al traguardo
molti a trony madonna altro che io 6
monte lui sa che internati salvala
salvala a specchio sta iniziando tra con
moto scusa ancora una vita solo quattro
bossoli
ci siamo devo fare non riuscire a far
questo chissà che cazzo di posto
dovrebbe essere studiato
adrid i quali guarda che casino apatia
tutti scampo alla pixar libia che se no
no
era un transessuale dai da melo buona è
impossibile ma c'è da fare ce la devo
far ma quella non era una donna
oddio ragazzi sparatemi nei commenti
quanto qualche punteggio faccio perché
io io no ma io dico 35 senti volta
l'ombrello
l'appeal del sogno che sono un pizza
no no ragazzi non mangiate mai pezza che
cucino io mai questo questo è un
avvertimento 17 bastardo punto no no ma
che cazzo ma basta al colore è la
sveglia mia la mattina non saremo mai 18
punti va bene va bene così lega va bene
così per essere la prima va bene così
l'elefante punta la bacchetta multiforme
in avanti ponendone l'estremità
inferiore leggermente a contatto con il
naso così come la proboscide di un pò
site elefante anche tu
userà il tuo nuovo naso per rifornirsi
di rinnovate energie
io mi sento un deficiente poi non lo so
ancora se ti metti dentro veti dentro
cosa ma che cazzo ragazzi sono
stanchissimo i volti alla fu la pasta
respinge
[Musica]
finché che giocatore di pallavolo
professionista sega ma che cazzo di lama
è quella della vita
gli attrezzi mi date cazzola 6 individua
ok spetta a me sarà semplice questo
guarda è a prova di ebete ma devo
riuscire a sbagliarlo da abbiate
pazienza potrebbe succedere fascismo
entra brutta la guarda ma guarda che
schifo ma [ __ ] annuisci se corretto fa
vj usa la sinistra se no non era sul
letto ma non so neanch'io che chiassoso
come braccio mi importa mi mette
tensione sta roba anche possibile non è
possibile che non riesca ad arrivare al
boss maritza le mancate
ok annuisci né corretto chiami pani j
chi cazzo questo l'ho accettata non è
possibile o vinto milioni di dollari
quadro boss è la cosa fai in pila così
vivo così stato arduo motivo fermi
ragazzi ok ok ok regala allegra rea si
no resisti 32
sì io sud il sudore il sudore per forza
troiata cielo fottutamente fatto bingo
gratis ogni giorno a scaldarmi anche se
mi mano una vita non importa
l'importante riunissimo
ciao ragazzi video se riesco a fare il
proprio di recente con facce multimetri
basta sono sono distrutto perché dovevo
sposare una pecora
io pensavo di fare altro nella vita mi
sono ritrovato a tosare le pecore ma va
bene così il disegnatore io io a questo
sono un fenomeno pieni bacchetta
multiforme nello stesso modo in cui
terresti ora penh durante un compito in
classe delicatamente con piglio sicuro
padroneggiando questa mossa l'allievo si
trasformerà il maestro e allo zero
esattamente così la penna a scuola ma
più o meno è la firma prima famiglia ma
vige 10 10 ragazzi così si prende 10 ai
conflitti di classe imparato ed aste
cosa che era così perché una si è
lanciata dalla torre di pisa qual è il
senso di tutto questo
no crozza più veloce che già faccio
fatica così il disegnatore vai vai vai
com'era no io giuro che sto sudando l'ho
già faccio più non prendi la bacchetta
mogli foglio nella mano destra e temi la
vicinale anche a sinistra non sa come
solo lei sa con marco che le due pende
il proprio pranzo è mio
la mia banana stones devo fare così
affetta
[Musica]
lo chiamarono ninja fabbri quattro boss
ragazzi sono tutti o perché non sono sto
solo andando praticamente manca in già
stessa così da fare
arriva la meta gara c'è una multa perché
c'è una mucca in mezzo alla strada fermi
ma affatto la come si suona justin
quando mamma sono un fenomeno a guidare
giuro gioiosa in semi ferma la pula sono
cazzi non ciò frena cazzo di scimmie
perché c'erano delle scimmie in mezzo
alla strada [ __ ] tu la tartaruga
listini va bè ragazzi diciamo che ho
voluto provare a fare un esperimento
siccome non sapevo se vario potesse
piacergli un ho provato a farlo fatemi
sapere se volete altri episodi su mario
io gli faccio tranquilli e possibilmente
quando sono più allenato perché questa è
stata la prima volta io però la finisco
qui perché sono distrutto anche ragazzi
come al solito sedi dove è piaciuto
lasciate un commento mi piace anche al
pagina di facebook e come non imita
tratta una descrizione essere avere city
scriveteli ci rivediamo il prossimo
video che da ragazzi